>> WE WILL TELL YOU HOW Y'ALL
DID IN A SECOND.
>> I'M AFRAID YOU WILL.
HERE YOU GO.
HERE IS THE FIRST TEAM.
STEPH CURRY, LUKA DONCIC.
THE JOKER WHO IS THE MVP.
KAWHI LEONARD AND GIANNIS.
>> SECOND TEAM.
>> OH, OKAY.
THAT SUPPER FIRST TEAM.
SECOND TEAM ALL NBA.
CHRIS PAUL AND DAMIAN LILLARD
AND JOEL EMBIID AND JULIUS
RANDLE AND LeBRON JAMES.
>> CONGRATS, JULIUS.
>> OKAY.
>> I DON'T THINK I CAN ARGUE.
>> I THINK I MAY HAVE A PROBLEM
WITH IT.
>> THIRD TEAM.
KYRIE, BRADLEY BEAL, RUDY
GOBERT AND JIMMY BUTLER AND PAUL
GEORGE.
TH
E
>> SURE.
THAT IS WHAT IT IS.
>> I MEAN, I THINK --
>> I THINK THAT IS A FAIR --
>> IT'S A FAIR QUESTION.
>> OH, YEAH.
NO DOUBT.
>> I DON'T EITHER ONE IS WRONG.
>> NO.
>> I THINK DAME PROPELLED HIS
TEAM FURTHER IN THE REGULAR
SEASON BECAUSE IT'S A REGULAR
SEASON AWARD, NOT A PLAYOFF
AWARD.
>> CORRECT.
>> IN THE REGULAR SEASON, DAME
HAD A BETTER YEAR.
>> LUKA HAD A TERRIFIC YEAR
ALSO.
>> YEAH, BUT HIS TEAM WASN'T AS
GOOD.
PORTLAND WAS A BETTER REGULAR
SEASON THAN THE MAVS.
MAVS WERE UP AND DOWN.
>> BUT IT'S NOT BECAUSE OF LUKA.
>> MAVS WERE A HIGHER SEED.
>> MAVS HAD A BETTER SEASON
RECORD.
>> IT'S DEBATABLE.
>> I THINK THERE WERE A LOT
OF --
>> I LIKE IT.
>> CONGRATULATIONS.
>> THEY BOTH WON 42 GAMES.
>> I LIKE IT AS IT WAS.
>> YEAH.
IT IS --
>> DID ANYBODY HAVE A GOOD
ARGUMENT, THOUGH?
>> WHAT DO YOU MEAN?
>> ONLY WESTBROOK WASN'T ON THE
LIST.
>> OKAY.
I'M THINKING WHO ELSE -- I'M
TALKING ABOUT IN THE LEAGUE.
JAYSON TATUM?
>> THAT WOULD BE ONE, YEAH.
>> HE COULD BE IN THE
CONVERSATION.
I'M JUST ASKING THAT.
>> JAYSON TATUM IS DEFINITELY IN
THE CONVERSATION.
>> BEN SIMMONS?
>> IN THE CONVERSATION.
>> ON THE LIST HONORABLE
MENTION?
>> YOU'RE GOOD WITH LeBRON
SECOND TEAM?
>> YEAH.
BECAUSE OF INJURIES.
>> WHO WAS ON THE THIRD TEAM?
>> PUT IT BACK UP.
>> PAUL GEORGE?
>> YOU WANT TO SEE THIRD TEAM UP
HERE, CHUCK?
>> YEAH.
SEE THE THIRD TEAM.
>> THE ONLY PERSON, YOU KNOW --
NO.
LeBRON IS LeBRON.
PAUL GEORGE HAD A GOOD YEAR.
HE'S REALLY PICKED IT UP IN THE
PLAYOFFS.
BUT INJURIES, MAN.
THIS INJURY THING IS A SERIOUS
THING RIGHT NOW.
THE NBA, I SAID IT A COUPLE OF
WEEKS AGO.
THE NBA GOING TO HAVE TO TAKE A
HARD LOOK ON TWO THINGS.
I DON'T THINK WE NEED TO SEND
OUR BEST PLAYERS TO THE
OLYMPICS.
NOBODY GIVES A CRAP IF WE WIN
THE OLYMPIC GOLD MEDAL.
EVERYBODY KNOW WE ARE THE BEST
BASKETBALL PLAYING COUNTRY IN
THE WORLD.
TO HAVE THE BEST PLAYERS REALLY
PLAY BASKETBALL YEAR-ROUND AS
MUCH AS THEY HAVE AND DO
OLYMPICS AND THEN START THE
SEASON AGAIN, I THINK THAT WOULD
BE JUST STUPID.
>> ANOTHER COUPLE OF NAMES.
DONOVAN MITCHELL.
>> OH, DONOVAN DIDN'T MAKE IT.
>> HE DIDN'T MAKE IT IN.
>> GO BACK.
GO BACK.
>> HE DIDN'T MAKE A TEAM?
>> NO, THAT IS WRONG.
THE WHOLE THING IS WRONG.
>> GO BACK TO SECOND TEAM.
>> BRADLEY BEAL.
>> THE WHOLE THING IS WRONG.
DONOVAN MITCHELL SHOULD HAVE
BEEN MVP.
>> THE BEST HE COULD HAVE BEEN
IS THIRD TEAM.
>> NO, YOU'RE TRIPPING, MAN.
YOU'RE TRIPPING.
>> NO.
I'M SAYING THE ONLY THING HE
COULD HAVE BEEN ON, KENNY, IS
THIRD TEAM.
THEN YOU GOT TO TAKE BRADLEY
BEAL --
>> IF DONOVAN MITCHELL IS NOT
ONE OF THE TOP 15 BASKETBALL
PLAYERS IN THE NBA.
>> THEY ARE WRONG ABOUT THAT
ONE.
>> GO TO THE THIRD TEAM, PLEASE.
>> NO.
BUT YOU COULD SAY THE SAME THING
ABOUT KEVIN DURANT IF HE IS NOT
ONE OF THE TOP -- HE IS NOT ON
THERE.
>> THIS IS --
>> THERE WERE SO MANY NAMES
MISSED.
>> YOU ONLY GOT TWO GUARDS ON
THE THIRD TEAM.
>> I DON'T WANT TO TAKE
ANYBODY'S SHINE AWAY TODAY.
>> FIRST OF ALL, BOTH -- HEY,
WAIT.
>> ONE OF THE TOP --
>> BOTH OF THOSE GUYS GOT SHINE.
YOU AIN'T TAKING NO SHINE AWAY.
>> I'M JUST SAYING, TODAY IS A
GREAT DAY FOR THOSE GUYS WHO
MAKE ALL NBA TEAM BUT DONOVAN
MITCHELL.
>> DONOVAN MITCHELL IS A
TERRIFIC PLAYER.
>> GUYS WHO MISSED --
>> OTHER GUYS MISSED ON THOSE
LISTS.
>> BRADLEY BEAL AND KYRIE IRVING
BOTH HAD FANTASTIC YEARS.
LISTEN.
WE LOVE DONOVAN BUT, LISTEN.
YOU HAVE TO MAKE A DECISION.
>> NUMBER ONE SEED.
WHY ARE UTAH JAZZ NUMBER ONE
SEASON?
>> DONOVAN MITCHELL.
>> HE IS THE BEST PLAYER ON TH